[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti allora innanzitutto
io vorrei fare i complimenti ai ragazzi
che sull che sono già saliti sul palco e
che salgono sul palco oggi perché il
fatto di aver scelto di condividere la
vostra idea di valore con noi oggi è
stato un gesto veramente coraggiosissimo
credo che con il vostro intervento voi
possiate cambiare anzi sicuramente
cambierete il punto di vista su quello
di cui andrete a parlare in alcune delle
persone che sono nel vostro pubblico ma
sapete questo viaggio della condivisione
e prezioso anche per voi non soltanto
per noi che vi ascoltiamo perché voi nel
prepararvi per raccontarci le preparare
il vostro discorso avete imparato a
conoscere meglio voi stessi e stata una
cosa molto molto importante per voi e
questo ve lo ritroverete è un regalo che
voi fate a noi ma è anche una cosa che
rimane a voi pensate che mondo sarebbe
se nessuno avesse il coraggio di
condividere le proprie idee
rimarremo tutti nella nostra scatola e
non scatterebbe la scintilla nel
cervello nel nostro cervello ovvero
quella che porta alla creazione alle
idee di valore
e proprio questa la mission di trade ed
alzate la mano quindi al pubblico tutti
alzate la mano se sapete che cosa è
trader
se avete mai sentito parlare dice del
wow wow
ok quindi abbiamo un pubblico
informatissimo comunque per chi per chi
vede ge
diciamo una cosa nuova in italia io in
questo momento e sono la leader diciamo
degli degli ato insegnanti degli atelier
e per chi non sapesse che cos'è voglio
raccontarvi dunque nacque circa cinque
anni fa fa parte di ted questo movimento
nacque circa questa piattaforma a me
piace dire movimento mandata una
piattaforma è anche un movimento come
animazioni
ok che probabilmente alcuni di voi avete
già visto perché sono animazioni che
sono state create da parte di cede per
aiutare gli insegnanti a svolgere il
proprio mestiere non vi invito veramente
se non l'avete mai visto ad andare a
dare un'occhiata
ma come si suol dire in italia la fame
vien mangiando e gli insegnanti come me
anch'io sono insegnante hanno
incominciato a chiedere a c'è già ed è
da quel punto c'era già di creare un
percorso per portare anche ragazzi sul
palco non soltanto gli adulti ed eccolo
che nacquero i 13 laboratori ecco che
nacque dice del club scusatemi i 13
lavoratori come noi li conosciamo oggi
attraverso i quali i ragazzi salgono sul
palco e si però imparano anche qualcosa
sullo storytelling sullo store boening
imparano anche utilizzare il socio media
imparano anche utilizzare in media a
disposizione in maniera efficace
oggi dice del club sono presenti in 130
paesi nel mondo e oggi ci sono
all'incirca 6000 419 19 the dead nel
mondo pensate che in italia soltanto nel
sono stati approvati 75 jazz club e noi
vogliamo fare in modo che questo numero
aumenti anzi sta aumentando in maniera
esponenziale come dunque noi abbiamo già
iniziato
a contattare individualmente tutti i
leader che possono essere docenti
possono essere formatori possono essere
membri della comunità non devono essere
per forza insegnanti delle scuole
chiunque si innamori un po di questo
progetto come è successo a me ea tanti
altri stiamo già contattando perché
vogliamo creare una rete viva una rete
attiva una rete di scambio sapete io
sono così entusiasta perché sono stata
così fortunata da essere invitata ed
proprio da che dai trader chiamiamolo
insomma perché a volte si fa un po di
confusione comunque e sempre c'è andrea
novembre a new york non sapevo di cosa
si trattasse era semplicemente un
insieme di insegnanti questi distingue
jokers come loro li chiamano che sono
semplicemente persone che amano i
ragazzi e che amano il loro mestiere
perché si tratta di quello si tratta di
valorizzare gli insegnanti ed i in
questo modo l'insegnante e avendo gli
strumenti e appunto a dati gli strumenti
che servono e più efficace
l'insegnante deve essere d'accordo anche
entusiasti dei ragazzi però questa
combinazione è vincente e quindi abbiamo
iniziato a fare quello infatti e poi vi
racconto che quest'autunno a torino dove
abito io ci sarà il primo raduno perché
samet mi sembra un po ambizioso comunque
chiamiamolo summit dei tre ex la blears
aler saran sarete ospiti i nostri e
durerà una esattamente come è stato a
new york per me io voglio un po ripetere
l'esperienza voglio condividerla con
tutti i miei colleghi trader linus e in
questo in questa occasione ci
racconteremo quello che stiamo facendo
quello che abbiamo fatto e magari poi
sarà un'occasione per creare un progetto
comune ma vero vivo non soltanto sulla
carta
organizzeremo anche dei workshop il
primo e si sta muovendo tutto molto
velocemente io sarò
e a gallarate domenica 25 febbraio per
chi fosse di milano o fosse in zone
volesse partecipare sarà nel pomeriggio
non so non ho ancora tutti i dati però
sarà il primo workshop diciamo informale
in cui io racconterò un po a tutti gli
insegnanti che ci saranno ma anche alle
persone che assisteranno questo evento
come si svolge il re del club è appunto
il beneficio che possono trarre loro e
il loro allievi io vorrei che ci
lasciassimo con una promessa oggi io vi
faccio vedere questo video racconto che
soltanto una condivisione di una cosa
che io ho fatto però è peering per
incentivare anche voi per fare scattare
anche voi in voi la scintilla
diciamo dell'entusiasmo per motivarvi un
po voglio soltanto condividere con voi
per quello per quel motivo li e
lasciarvi con la promessa di rivederci
il prossimo anno con un video racconto
che contenga dei pezzettini di tutti i
tre dead in italia non soltanto il mio
che ne dite
grazie
[Applauso]
pag e voi mare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no grazie
comunque questo è questo video è stato
realizzato noi abbiamo la fortuna di
avere ci tengo molto a raccontarvi anche
questo perché poi anche voi facciate
delle sinergie con la community
il politecnico ovviamente io non ho
fatto col cellulare questa cosa quindi
ci tengo a parlare anche di loro e mi
sei innamorato un po anche il
politecnico 22 persone del politecnico
professore del progetto e quindi loro ci
seguono e insegnano ai ragazzi diciamo
tutta la parte di come fare le foto come
fare i video in maniera molto molto
veloce però c'è anche questa competenza
quindi vi invito a pensare anche se
magari avete delle università vicine e
qualcuno che potrebbe appunto
innamorarsi anche del vostro gruppo è
sempre una bella cosa avere questo
cambio ultimi e scambio cosa io volevo
ringraziare andrea e fargli i
complimenti perchè io l'anno scorso ero
qua come spettatrice mai più avrebbe
fatto di essere sul palco oggi direi che
abbiamo fatto un sacco di cose insieme e
lui comunque
e un bravissimo diciamo e host no è un
bravissimo a faust è un meraviglioso
organizzatore di eventi e questo come
l'altro è bellissimo quindi complimenti
e grazie a voi
buon proseguimento
[Applauso]